foreign
hey you guys what's going on uh okay I'm
always like I'm always paranoid the
[ __ ]
microphone's gonna turn itself off uh
what's going on everybody it's Tuesday
and it's time for another movie review
uh mango just pet said in the uh
comments that this is a great film one
of Browning's best
yeah I kind of feel like I need to see
more of Todd Browning's early films I
was watching a thing earlier
that was kind of it was about freaks but
they were talking about like a lot of
the background before it like a lot of
the movies that he had made like with
Lon Chaney and stuff like that like back
in the 20s and some of those sounded
batshit insane like in the best possible
way so I'm just kind of like yeah I
don't know why I haven't seen this and
actually like um there was one called
the Unholy three which actually had uh
the little person actor who plays Hans
in this one and actually that guy the
guy that played Hans
um it was actually his idea to do this
movie you know what I mean like he was
the one that wanted to do it so yeah
freaks you guys from 1932 uh this was
the movie that Todd Browning did pretty
much like after Dracula I guess he'd
been wanting to do it for a while
like since the 20s because I don't know
if you guys know but Todd Todd Browning
before he got into uh being a director
he actually when he was 16 ran away from
home and joined the circus
so uh yeah so he worked as a Carnival
Barker and stuff like that for a while
so he was like taught he was you know
making movies about stuff that he had a
lot of experience with I thought it was
okay movie it's pretty good it's very
simple story uh it's almost kind of like
a variety show just a bunch of scenes
with freaks in them real freaks you know
people know arms and legs and people
with no without a lower half and they
were like right out of the sideshows
um a bunch of what they call pin heads
and
um and then it just individual scenes of
you know
comedy type stuff they're almost like
little comedy skits and some of the [ __ ]
was kind of like uh terrible you know
what I mean where the normal people were
treating the uh the the the sideshow
freaks uh with this disrespect you know
but then it turned out that is as the
story unfolds most of the normal people
in this story are are the real freaks
yeah and they're our [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] and they're Freaks and then the
the sideshow freaks are actually the
cool people they're they're sticking
together
and like I said this was kind of one of
the first films to do that I feel like
which may have because I've I was
watching a couple of documentaries about
like a lot of the cultural context
behind this
and I okay so I think it's going a
little bit far to say that this ruined
Todd Browning's career although I will
note that he only made four movies after
this and this movie
uh when it came out was almost
universally reviled
um because and I don't think it's for
the reasons that maybe people thought it
was because you have to think that like
prior to the 1930s maybe and I was
watching this uh really interesting
documentary about this where they were
talking about you know the 1920s was
like real big like the Eugenics movement
was like really really popular and they
said another thing too that like in
horror movies of that time period had
featured you know actors with
disabilities and things like that before
but they were always the villains
essentially so I think that people
weren't really ready to see a movie that
had people with actual disabilities like
that or deformities or whatever you want
to call them uh portrayed in a
sympathetic light where the normal
people were the villains not all the
normal people in the movie were villains
because like some of the people were
okay
but the villains of the piece were
clearly Cleopatra the beautiful trapeze
artist and Hercules the circus strong
man yeah he is strong though
it's just fun well he was a strong man
for that time yeah he's big but he's
skinny I I was just like he's doing all
his muscles and I'm going keep working
on it bro
keep working on it well like I said
there wasn't it's not like they had a
lot of like competition back yeah you
know what I mean yeah yeah that was
another thing is that they showed
there's a lot of like dudes running
around shirtless and they're doing work
and I just I have a hard time believing
that those were just average physiques
for the time because those dudes were
skeletal
and I by today's standards you would
just think man that dude is really
[ __ ] skinny well you have to think
too that this was like right around the
[ __ ] depression and all that kind of
stuff so they probably weren't eating
all that good yeah
slasher Fred said it just shows what you
consider to be Normal and abnormal yeah
I mean and there's been it's crazy
because I kind of feel like um mango
just pointed out this was banned in the
UK until the 50s yeah and um like I said
it came out
here's the thing like we watched the
version the version that's on HBO Max
it's 64 minutes and as far as I know
that is the version of it that remains
however
the original version of the film was
actually an hour and a half long
the one that Todd Browning made but they
did test screenings back then
and the audiences were so horrified
people ran out people flipped out one
woman tried to sue because she said she
had a miscarriage because of it you know
what I mean like everyone was like
[ __ ] drama queen you know what I mean
so MGM we're just kind of like okay well
we can't have this and they went behind
Todd Browning's back and cut the film
and even in spite of that
um it's still like when it came out it
pretty much got Savaged I think there
was a couple critics I think the critic
of their of the New York Times liked it
but it's like mostly everyone was like
this who would even make this this is
like appalling and all this other kind
of [ __ ] there's some sensitive [ __ ]
man they were man back then holy [ __ ]
and that well the thing about it that I
know for a fact I don't think that this
footage exists anymore
but from [ __ ] that they talked about
back at the time stuff that was cut out
um they took out a lot of stuff where
they actually kind of showed the freaks
um you know doing that to Cleopatra at
them like making her into like the
chicken lady or whatever or I guess she
was supposed to be a duck maybe I'm not
really sure but like so they had there
was more shots of them like [ __ ] her
up like doing that kind of stuff also uh
Hercules the strong man they castrated
him uh yeah and like at the end there's
like a scene of him like singing like in
a really really high like castrati type
of voice with like with her like
quacking like next to him yeah yeah
that'd have been cool so that I know
it's like they should have left that in
but like I said they were just very
delicate back then and I guess they just
couldn't take it it was just you know
just a story about a bunch of carnies
you know and they're kind of [ __ ]
semi-criminal and uh
Cleopatra starts extorting the little uh
[ __ ] guy he's not a dwarf he's a
[ __ ] uh he's got you know he he looks
totally proportionate so to his his
fiancee she looks totally proportional
even though you know in real life that's
actually his sister is it okay their
brother and sister they're just totally
proportionate look like little people
and uh
Cleopatra is uh milking him for money
you know stringing him along like she's
a complete one yeah and then behind his
back laughing at him and then eventually
she ends up just mocking him to his face
she's actually sleeping with a strong
man Hercules and uh
they offer it ends up in the end you
know all the freaks offer kind of like a
a this ceremony to accept her as one of
them you know what I mean that she could
be part of the gag and she laughs at him
rejects them she's like she's just like
horrified by that suggests because she
clearly like thinks that she's better
though yeah yeah and
the freaks are just people
you know
they're very well humanized in the movie
they're not they're not yeah into
monsters which I think they didn't get
back in the year no they really did it
like because this is just showing them
just doing regular [ __ ] like just being
normal people and I think people were
just they didn't they weren't ready to
see that I guess I don't know why but
they had all the little pinheads and
they're all dressed up as girls with
things they were dressed as girls even
if they weren't girls I don't understand
well that one
um the one that was in there that you
were talking about that's kind of like
the famous guy um
schlitzy yeah that was uh that was a man
well they said that the reason because I
was looking on the Wikipedia because he
has his own Wikipedia Pages because like
I said he's quite famous
um they because he was in sideshows all
of his life pretty much yeah and they I
was trying to figure out I was like was
that a thing like why they put them all
in dresses and stuff I think that part
of the thing was one of the characters
that he played like when he was in the
sideshows
um they were trying to like introduce
another element of like weirdness or
like ambiguity yeah and also they said
and this is kind of like [ __ ] up but
well because he was microcephalic
um he had he was about at the same level
as like a three-year-old or something
like that
so um sometimes like when he started to
get a little bit older uh he was
incontinent so they said they that he
had to wear diapers all the time yeah so
they said so it made it easier like just
to put him in outfits and like like that
yeah because it was like easier to
change the diapers yeah but yeah that
was if you guys were a fan of the old
Howard Stern Show back when Howard was
funny he had a guest on a regular guest
all the time from The Wack Pack it was
Beetlejuice and he looked like he had a
little head just like out of that like
with the word the micro is definitely
yeah and then his nickname is
Beetlejuice I think he's dead now but uh
he was like that too he and he he'd crap
his pants and would talk and not really
make a whole lot of sense but he liked
being on the show you know they were
well they were nice to him you know what
I mean they would goof on him but he did
you know
he was getting paid and
you know he was getting invited to all
these little things a lot of Howard
Stern's A Wack Pack liked being on the
show they liked the attention but um
because he wouldn't be doing anything
else you know and that was just kind of
the thing
if you are a freak you better learn how
to make money out of that you might want
to join something like a circus so
that's the way it was back then you
needed protection you needed income you
needed some way of
showing off what made you different you
know you could just get get an amount of
security behind it well and there was a
community there like you know like
everyone would be cool with you like you
probably if you had to especially back
then and even probably nowadays yeah
um you know back then like you couldn't
live a regular life everyone would
probably like [ __ ] will you be
throwing things at you be thrown to the
Wolves you wouldn't survive you had to
be taken care of so they went to those
circuses they were you know they they
showed the the the the micros they call
it micro encephalet micro encephaly they
showed them yeah and they were just
playing like kids and just you know
hanging out with each other yeah they're
just like yeah yeah and then you can say
hey I'm acting in the movie crawling
along with the other ones and having fun
and
um yeah I think the one the one famous
one you're talking about he says some
stuff and he doesn't make any goddamn
sense but they said I don't think he
could make sense no he couldn't make the
sense no you just well like I said he's
a voice but it just didn't make any
sense well like I said he was about like
a three-year-old so he was like a you
know he had like a toddler like a
vocabulary like he could talk and stuff
but the thing about it was that from
everything that I read about schlitzy
what that he um he loved being in the
circus he just thought it was the
coolest thing ever and yeah and
everybody that knew him said that he was
like super happy and everything and when
he got a little bit older and like he
couldn't be in the circus that like he
was really sad about that yeah because
he just liked being around all the
people and he had a good time I think
the dude that amazed me was the black
dude with not not he had no arms or legs
it was just a body to head yeah yeah and
he with his mouth gets us gets out a
cigarette and a match strikes that match
and lights that cigarette just with his
lips yeah and he's smoking and talking
yeah he's just and he's just quite
famous he's just a normal guy just with
not in the arms and legs and just he
pulled that damn cigarette out and he
didn't roll it but I would imagine
somebody else had to roll his stuff for
him but because it was a hand rolled
cigarette but uh he pulled it out in a
match and lit it on the matchbox yeah
that was kind of one of his things that
like he would do like for people to so
he had the matchbox he set it down on
the ground he had the match and then the
cigarette in his mouth and struck the
match and then held it in a certain way
so the flame went up and got the name
spit that out and then just sat there
and was smoking and talking
and uh it was pretty impressive trick
then they had a girl was born with no
arms she's quite cute actually of no
arms and she's eating at the table with
her feet drinking with her feet and
stuff
um but it looks like she didn't even
have little stops of arms it looked like
she didn't have shoulder blades it
looked like the price yeah like I said
pretty much everybody like all the
performers in this were famous they were
they were scouted from actual so they
were all like very well known yeah at
the time like from being in various
carnivals and things but it's a very
simple story uh but it's kind of an
enjoyable watch uh it's not shocking by
today's standards at all
the deformities are not gross or
anything they're just regular
deformities that you'd see like you
didn't see anybody that you know one of
the worst deformities I've seen was just
somebody who had been born with syphilis
and they come out look just like Eddie
from Iron Maiden look like a living
corpse and Matt can you imagine that
that's not even your fault
you know I mean nothing you can do just
born with that damn well that's what I
mean it just kind of um yeah but that's
kind of the thing about this movie that
like I said I think people in the 30s
just weren't ready for it yeah because
prior to this you know people had seen
horror movies and things like that but I
kind of feel like there had there had
always been like a really strong
association between somebody that was
funny looking or somebody that was weird
or ugly or something like that and evil
you know what I mean
um whereas this movie it very much shows
these performers it doesn't even show
them performing in the circus it's all
behind the scenes yeah they're just in
there and they're just in their trailers
doing regular [ __ ] it's like you know
the bearded lady she has a baby like
it's her in the human skeleton like they
have a baby together and everybody's
like oh look at the baby you know what I
mean they're just doing regular normal
people [ __ ] and for some reason like
people in the 1930s just were not having
it like they couldn't and you know
what's really [ __ ] sad about this
this what I was reading about like the
background behind the making of this
movie this actually really upset me so
I'm like while they were making this
movie
some of the people like complained about
the quote-unquote freaks eating in the
commissary you know what I mean like
when they're and so they had to make
them a tent so they'd eat outside
because because some of the people were
like oh we can't eat without throwing up
because all of those people are in here
yeah and I was just like man people
sucked backs
they had a very small [ __ ] awful very
small window of acceptability uh yeah
back then and I was like that's awful uh
but I think I think you know
a lot of people were sheltered they
didn't have energy yeah they didn't have
they didn't have television wasn't
around yet
so it the learning Pro Life Learning was
took a lot longer back then because you
didn't have access to information you
didn't get the exposure
most people never left their hometown
yeah there's a big deal to go to
California oh man I'm here in a big city
now I'm gonna go try to get one of them
jobs over there at Hollywood you know
what I mean
it's just
and a lot of them girls just ended up
being hookers you know that's usually
how it went
uh but
people were sheltered back then yeah and
that you still have societies like that
yeah China's like that to a certain
extent
Japan and Korea not as much but they you
know they're they're deformed if
somebody had any kind of deformities or
regular irregularities are just kind of
shunned you know yeah because there's
still that really strong which we had
here like you know that people had here
like back then obviously that it's rude
and unpleasant to see that person get
them out of here don't well and they and
and I think they that people have were
making a connection between like your
outer appearance and your moral fiber
like you know what I mean like oh well
God must have bladed you like you must
be a terrible person like if that
happened to you I don't think in the
East they look at it that way though
that's no I was talking about here yeah
that goes back to the Greek golden age
well yeah the Greeks thought that that
Form and Function were [ __ ] one thing
you know what I mean so you looked a
certain way because you were bad or good
yeah
but in the East it's more like well it's
impolite to show this person in public
because it will offend them so we're
going to hide this person yeah that's
how they'll do it which is [ __ ] up
that's their justification for it well
this is polite Society we can't show
these people yeah
um which is you know as this
Jed we're eating in a damn restaurant
and it just
woman came around a corner and her
husband's holding her back and she's I
[ __ ] trying to get the jetty and
kissed on her and [ __ ] I love you and
she obviously it had a stroke but
they're basically just having to keep
her from running around well who's to
say she can't go into public
you know what I mean her family can take
her to public they were watching out for
her yeah she was friendly you know it
wasn't her fault that she had a stroke
but she definitely was not in control of
her faculties yeah but she was pleasant
just annoying because you know she wants
to get in your mix yeah but that's just
you know but I mean she didn't have to
put up with that you don't see that
anybody it's just a regular person you
know older person and you know I had a
stroke
and uh
she's gonna try to get in your [ __ ]
face yeah tell you she loves you and
then let me kiss you she was kissing on
her and I was like that's all she does
she said hi to everybody and I love you
to everybody and [ __ ] give me a kiss
and just that's that just that was a
trip Tammy said it might have been
Alzheimer's oh yeah maybe then that yeah
maybe maybe not but they were taking her
at least she was happy yeah and she was
experiencing she seemed to be having a
good time
experience coming outside you know
that's all her husband was [ __ ]
almost all had her on a leash almost
yeah I was like Hey cook come on come on
let's go over here and like him yeah
go over here come on come on there
pushing her and she's uh
yeah Tom sex says Beetlejuice is still
alive is he still alive 54 years old 54
all right I thought he died so for some
reason some of them have died since I
don't remember which ones it was
he also said uh doesn't Florida have a
sideshow freak town for the Freaks Like
portrayed in the episode of The X-Files
yes uh yeah we do Gibsonton
yeah that's where they did the crab boy
murders yeah did we do a show about that
I don't remember if we did a whole show
yeah Grady Styles like the guy he was
Lobster Boy you know like he had the
hands I don't know what do they call
that I don't know they're they're that's
a damn disorder yeah yeah something
dactly
yeah they had this woman she was
beautiful as hell she was a a
news reporter and she had that and they
gave her false hands to wear yeah and
nobody knew that she had that
because they kind of kept him out of
shot but she was real good looking she
was one of the local news reporters in
one of these states I forgot they did a
little show on her this was back in the
90s they did the show water us off
you know it was like damn you know
nobody and she said that nobody knew
because she had like the fake she had
fake hands that she put her hands inside
some prosthetic halves and she'd go
through papers and stuff but it was just
it was just on the surface yeah but she
looked like a supermodel
yeah that's uh that's interesting yeah
that's um that Grady Styles guy yeah he
had that he had that too and he was like
I said he was always inside shows as
Lobster Boy and then he ended up killing
somebody that would actually make a good
show maybe because that dude was like
super interesting but um but yeah so
like I said the thing that happened with
this when they ended up cutting up half
an hour cutting half an hour out of it
because of the whole castration and all
that other kind of stuff they took all
that out but even so
um
it's it lost money one and like
everybody like I said it just got
[ __ ] Savaged and I think MGM didn't
even let it finish its run like it
pulled it they pulled it out of theaters
and it got banned in the UK a couple
other countries too I think so it was
like a big deal it really didn't get
rediscovered I thought this was kind of
interesting it really didn't get
rediscovered and appreciated for what it
was until the early 1960s and actually
what ended up happening was like it got
rediscovered kind of on the French Art
House circuit yeah like they ended up
seeing it they were like oh my God this
is brilliant and so and I think because
as the 60s went on I was reading a thing
that said
um you know because in the 60s like the
word freak started to take on a more
positive connotation you know what I
mean it's like these are people that are
you know [ __ ] on by society and they're
just kind of like they've formed their
own family they're you know it's
humanizing them and they get back at
their oppressors and I think people
really dug that like I don't really
think they got that in the 30s because
the cultural context was different but
when the 60s came along this freaks
actually got rediscovered a little bit
and started going like on the midnight
movie circuit and it eventually
developed this like huge cult following
obviously which like I said nowadays you
know everybody's in people are talking
about like American Horror Story which
did a season that was kind of based
around this and
you know so and you know the Ramones
very famously like use some of it and
it's a lot of that big scene like at the
dinner table with the one of us chant
that's been used in like lots and lots
of things but you know what I mean
um Tom syk says a Florida paranormal
show about multiple different paranormal
cases would be cool including the lady
who spontaneously combusted in her room
oh yeah I remember that I remember that
lady I remember reading about that in um
uh what do you call it uh what's it
[ __ ] what's the one with the museum
Ripley's Believe It or Not yeah yeah
yeah
uh mr88 said I would rather a random
person kiss me than Christian me yeah me
too probably
me too probably yeah uh Mr 80 it said
the woman you were talking about where
her name was Bree Walker the girl the
hands she was married to the
sportscaster too okay all right yeah
yeah that's um
yeah I used to see that a lot in uh
sideshows I guess but like nowadays I
guess because they have better
Prosthetics and stuff like that so I
guess if you're born I don't know if
it's the exact same disorder I remember
her hands I think it was just two it was
yeah it's like two yeah there's like
that kind of it looks real bony Knuckles
real bony Knuckles on them you know they
they look like extraterrestrial like
some other alien yeah kinda
but she put her put him inside some of
these gloves that they had built for it
on low res television back then you know
CRT screen TVs you could it was kind of
fuzzy enough where you could get away
with it nobody knew
but she was like like a super bottle and
the guy she looked like a like like a 10
you know for that's how I remember she
was cute
well you could probably look her up
nowadays yeah he did yeah what I'm just
saying you could probably look up a
picture of her and see what she looks
because I don't I've heard of her but I
don't think I don't know what she looks
like hold on
um
wait I just saw it Bree Walker Brie
Walker Bree Walker b-r-e-e uh Richard
Brown said Rondo Hatton always played a
baddie because of his illness yeah
um even though I will say in the what
was the one movie that he was in that
was on Mystery Science Theater
um
he was called The Creeper in it but that
wasn't the name of the movie I think
that was one of the titles what the [ __ ]
was the name of that thing but yeah he
was in that and he was
a villain but he was like a sympathetic
villain you know what I mean like I mean
he was still a villain like he still
killed people and he was essentially
like a serial killer which is not good
but they did kind of make him a little
bit more sympathetic that was the one
with the blind lady like the blind piano
player lady it was kind of like a
Frankenstein type story to be fair
and like she could she wasn't scared of
him because she couldn't see him and
stuff like that he had I can't remember
what the name of his disorder was
but he just had that it was that I think
it's that one where like the bones in
your face like don't stop growing so he
just had like this really really big
face you know what I mean yeah but it
was that kind of thing we were um that's
her right there oh yeah yeah okay that's
yeah she's familiar
so she's she's as I remembered her
pretty much
yeah
Camp guy said I remember seeing freak
shows at the Atlanta Fairground in
Lakewood Georgia in the mid to late 60s
I'm an old fart
yeah I kind of feel like I mean
I think you didn't see them or it wasn't
as widespread for a while but then I
kind of feel like in the 90s it almost
had a little bit of a Resurgence as
people were kind of like you know
because they had like the Jim Rose
Sideshow and all that kind of stuff
although a lot of those a lot of the
people in that were usually like you
know people that
you know had like tattoos all over their
body or like or did like stunt type
things like rather than having been born
with a particular thing but I think that
there were some because I was watching
something the other day that had um
that had a girl that was in one of those
that she was kind of like cuckoo the
bird girl who was in this movie who was
in freaks like she was the one that was
like dancing on the table at the wedding
um she had the same I think she had the
same disorder as that girl and I think
she was also like did the same costume
like an homage to her so you know what I
mean
it's talking about Cirque du Soleil
and then wait a minute where was the
other thing that I wanted to talk about
uh let's see so yeah all
so
um yeah they also had the guy that was
that didn't have any legs like that guy
was pretty famous too like he he would
go around as I think I think his staging
was like the half boy or something like
that and the conjoined twin sisters and
everything like that but like I said
it's interesting because
I was watching this thing and they were
talking about is freaks really a horror
movie in the purest sense of the word no
no I mean I guess it's sort of is
because of you know but not really I
don't know if I'd call it
it's a Revenge story like it's a Revenge
Thriller but really at the beginning
like for the first two thirds of it
comedy I've it's almost like a comedy or
like just a domestic drama type thing
because basically all it all it's doing
is showing
just the background relationships and
stuff like that of all of these people
and just establishing
their humanity and establishing like how
what their regular lives are like
the first part of the movie actually it
kind of follows almost like a Vaudeville
format where it's a bunch of scenes and
some little acts that happen with little
jokes in it yeah but they kind of Link
together to paint a picture of what the
hell's going on with this group of
people and then it builds up to to
Revenge story at the end where the bad
people get get what they deserve
basically well
maybe it might have been going overboard
but they were they [ __ ] they [ __ ]
around and found out that's something
Jenny said that [ __ ] that's what I said
around and found out they [ __ ] around
with them little people and they found
out man I'm just well okay I mean you
could say that it's a little harsh what
they did to Cleopatra I don't think it
is because
I mean one she was the worst she was a
monster she was a Monster yeah I mean
she was just a horrible horrible person
and didn't really care who knew it and
she's like hey [ __ ] you I'm sure y'all
get away with it she also planned to
kill him so I guess she did that's what
I mean she was gonna kill him she was
gonna kill him and I think that the best
thing about the Revenge that they took
on her was that they didn't kill her no
it made her they made her what she most
hated and they're like now you have now
you see what we have to deal with all
the time from people like you like now
you're gonna experience that yeah so I
think that was like the perfect Revenge
honestly took Hercules manhood see yeah
that's what I'm saying so it was like
perfect I can't believe they like took
that yeah but it was good writing it's
just the people were sensitive at the
time and they they didn't they didn't
want the finger pointed back at them
they probably assaulted them too because
they wanted to see these they wanted to
see these Sideshow people as the bad
guys when the bad guys won they were
like oh [ __ ] that's how it usually was
up until then and honestly like even a
movie that Todd Brown yeah they didn't
want to get they I think they didn't
want it I think it made people
uncomfortable yeah well because even a
movie that Todd Browning had done a few
years before this one that had
um Harry Earls the little person had him
in it
um that was called the Unholy three and
he was in it but he was like a bad guy
yeah like the the carnies were like bad
guys they were um like one was a
ventriloquist and I can't remember what
the third one was but they were scamming
people like and Harry Earls he played a
guy who would he pretended to be a baby
yeah you know what I mean because you
know he was he was real little and he
had like that real baby face so he would
pretend to be a baby like to scam people
out of money and [ __ ] like that so I
think people were really comfortable
watching stuff like Phantom of the Opera
or you know London after midnight or
something like that where it's like the
the horrific looking person was indeed
the villain yeah but when you just
showed them as regular people just with
regular lives doing regular [ __ ] like
just hanging their laundry out and
you're the monster right and that and
and that the beautiful like the
beautiful people are mean are mean and
horrible and cruel and the worst and are
[ __ ] these people over then I don't
think people were I don't think they
were ready to deal with that because
this was really kind of the first movie
that had done that well what's fun is
that uh what I think is strange is that
the first thing that said in the movie
is when you're going in you're going
into the freak Show and the car those
Carnival Barker out there and he says
you know come in and see these freaks
basically he says you're gonna you laugh
at him you despise them you disgusted
and it's and it's nothing more than the
luck of your birth has prevented you
from being one of them as the first time
that they said that
your birth you're not one of them and
see that was a that was a very very
insightful thing to say to to an
audience of the 1930s they're like
you're just lucky that you're born
normal but some people are
you know yeah and they it's like you
know they advising them and you're doing
this and that and you're laughing at
them and uh you know just by luck of
your birth yeah so there's really
nothing special about you okay and uh so
they they lay it right out in the
beginning of the movie
so I don't know why the audience the
audience didn't absorb that message
evidently I guess not well I want to
absorb that message and that's the thing
too a lot of uh later critics have like
you know analyzing this movie they're
like this is a very overtly
anti-eugenics movie too because there's
a scene very early on in the movie where
one lady and I think um I don't remember
if it's like if it's the historic woman
or something like that and like the
microcephaly people but they're all just
like playing in the woods and then these
two guys like come walking along and one
of them's like those people it's like
they should have been drowned at Birth
or whatever smothered at Birth or
whatever and then it's like we have to
get them out of here what are they doing
on our land and all this other kind of
crap but then the other guy like sees
them and he's just like nah you guys are
good yeah you can stay yeah the Eugenics
things you know it kind of I can
understand
to an amniocentesis and if somebody's
going to be horribly deformed you might
want to go ahead and prevent that birth
aboard it start over because why would
you condemn somebody to that
but there's a difference between
horribly deformed and just unusual like
yeah a friend Tito is a dwarf working
over at Universal Studios and Disney
he's a great dude and he
comes to the club and [ __ ] talks
about Dwarven women and just women in
general you know and he can talk up a
storm and dudes he's a great man he's
short so what right and then you go on
um Instagram
and uh if I can see see in Central and
South America they don't have as much
amniocentesis so dwarves are born what
dwarves aren't really being born in the
United States like they used to be it's
almost kind of like
it's almost kind of like uh wiping out a
whole
species of people in a certain way you
know so here in North America most of
the dwarves we have come from Central
and South America
well you know me being on these little
Fitness rings and looking at
bodybuilders they got some Fitness and
bodybuilding chicks that are dwarves and
and they're cute real cute I can show
you pictures of them
who's to say who are we to say that a
person like that can't be born why would
she why would the parents go well you
know what
that that child is going to be born a
dwarf let's start over
I don't know man yeah I don't know I'm
comfortable with that I mean I don't
really like the idea of that but it's
like I mean ultimately it's up to the
parents obviously yeah but but I can see
if they're like if this child is gonna
suffer horribly yeah you know the kids
got it is fused together with a twin and
you know like I've seen they had that
spider dude remember the two kids two
guys and fused together and they were
both you know
real low intelligence and he just walked
around like a damn spider and uh no man
they were that was back in the 80s I
don't think they lived very long
um I can understand preventing something
like that but
and it kind of we're talking about
Eugenics all right they can you know the
uh the Germans of the BET cross were
putting dwarves trying to get rid of
dwarves
you know uh at least some of them they
had some of them in concentration camps
and stuff they tried to figure out what
it was but one of the comments was is
that we can't have one of the things
that eugenesis would think is is that
especially ones where race has become
politicized or or Not Race but just your
configuration is now politicized they
went there the German thinking at the
time was we can't have all these dwarves
because what they do is they marry each
other and in a few centuries we'll have
an entire species of dwarves and they
will be like a voting block that will
vote against us or you know I mean they
might be adversaries
that's a weird danking man that's nice
it is it's it's collectivist type
thinking
um
just because they're short it doesn't
make them a racial enemy or something
you know it's [ __ ] ridiculous but see
that's the way they thought but see
that's kind of the thing and I feel and
I feel like yeah the 1920s and 1930s
it's like it's very very easy
particularly back then to other people
who are different from you even if it's
just like something like dwarfism which
doesn't seem like that big of a deal no
like but it's just like well they're not
like me so yeah you know I mean you saw
with every like everything like that
whether it was race or whether it was
like you know this kind of stuff and
like I said I think that's why this
movie made people so uncomfortable back
then was because it was just showing
them as normal
people yeah like they were just doing
normal [ __ ] like just you know you know
they had normal relationships they had
normal like even the Siamese twin girls
like they had separate husbands and yeah
you know and it's like one of my
favorite jokes in that movie was um you
know because one of the one of the girls
was already
um Violet and Daisy their names because
I think they used their real names in
the movie but they were quite famous as
well like on the sideshow circuit back
then
um one of them was already married
and then and he was always kind of like
complaining because
you know he's like well I want my wife
to stay here and like the sister is like
no we're leaving and he's like God damn
it you know what I mean because it's
like not anything he could do about it
right yeah so and then like the other
one like the owner of the circus like
asked her to marry you know marry him
and the the two like husbands like make
a joke like oh well you're gonna have to
come over and visit us sometime or
something like that and I was just like
it was so funny because it's like they
didn't really have a choice you know
what I mean because the two women
couldn't be separate because they were
you know they were conjoined yeah and
they were fighting over who you know I
don't want my wife in bed all morning
because because you're having a hangover
right yeah because one of them would get
[ __ ] up and then she wouldn't want to
get up yeah and then one of them would
be making out with her husband and the
one that wasn't making out she could
feel it yeah she was like oh nice you
know
yeah it was yeah so it was like funny
but but like I said I mean we can watch
it now it's like oh that's like kind of
cute or whatever but I think like back
then they were just like really
horrified and scandalized yeah and I was
just kind of like and in a way like I
don't know how much Todd Browning agreed
with this but they even tried to the way
that they marketed this movie if you see
any of the um posters from the time
where it's just they it was very like
um Sensational because they were trying
to you know say stuff's like what you
know is this a man is it a woman like
dude siamese twins like do they have sex
with each other you know what I mean
it's like all this other kind of stuff
that they were putting on the poster to
make it seem like as salacious as
possible but I mean and like looking at
it now just like man that's a little bit
[ __ ] up like putting that on the
poster when they showed the Siamese twin
when they first introduced you to the
Siamese twin girls
uh they showed to the audience that you
somebody could touch one of the twin the
other twin could tell could with her
eyes closed could tell what that person
had done right so they could feel each
other through each other which I don't
know how true that is yeah that might
have been just for the movie yeah I
don't know I don't think I don't think
it actually they actually like that I
don't think their nervous systems are
that closely intertwined I mean I guess
it would depend
like you said on depends on how much how
much they shared like that one girl
who's basically got two heads
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think there is
some of that going on yeah I saw a
doctor but they're fused way you know
they're her upper body's a little bit
wider but they're fused together yeah
these two were kind of more fused yeah
um just kind of like on the backs of
their shoulders like just like right
along here it seemed like and I think he
I think I think the girl on the right
controls all the limbs on the right the
girl on the left controls all the girl
they they it's a teamwork to run because
I don't think they could feel each
other's the opposite legs
but see the thing about that it's like I
don't know I kind of feel like there's
sort of thing where you know people are
probably I the reason I liked that they
put that kind of joke in there about
like the husband joke and it's like well
you'll have to come over and visit us
sometimes it's like you know I mean just
like the way they framed it was like
kind of funny because they were just
making a joke about it but I liked that
they did that because it almost kind of
like deflated because you know everybody
like wonders about that kind of stuff
yeah it was just group sex what the hell
right but I mean it's just like anything
else you just have to like learn to work
around whatever you got going on you
know what I mean so yeah you're gonna
have to like work around that and I
think people are curious about it and
that's natural so I think that it's
interesting that they just put it kind
of like front and center of the movie
like that and it was and they were just
like making like gentle jokes about it
like oh yeah well what are you gonna do
it's like you know what I mean it's not
like you have a choice yeah I think uh
the original one that they the the
Chinese the two Chinese Brothers where
the word changing the one that they
named siamese twins after they were both
married to different women they were
were you and I think they had children
with those women too yeah I believe they
did yeah so you know that all has to
happen in the same room yeah which like
I said I don't know how they worked it
out I probably didn't care
well as I mentioned it's it's not like
and the thing about it is that if you
were born like that I mean it wouldn't
really seem
weird to you I guess because it's like
you wouldn't know any other way of being
that was just like the way yeah but the
the wives well yeah I know that but it's
like but they had to know what they were
getting and yeah you would think yeah
you know what I mean so they had to
before the best part of the deal that's
what I mean you just had to be cool with
it because like I said it's not like
they have a choice yeah you can't really
do anything because they all have to go
they all have to go places together all
four of them probably
yeah yeah
I can see how that would get real
annoying though like if you wanted to go
like in One Direction like that's why I
was laughing about the whole thing go
together yeah it's like well it's like
well I don't want to go over there well
too bad we're going over there you know
what I mean it's really gonna [ __ ]
suck yeah and that's that's why I
thought that was funny too like the with
the one girl's husband like complaining
about when one of them got drunk and
just laid around in bed and the wife
also has to lay right in bed because she
can't get up you know what I mean when
the other one's just laying there but
yeah so
it's just it's crazy to me how I mean
the reaction to this movie was just
I I it just like freaks me out yeah yeah
I've seen her before yeah that's that
little Dwarven Fitness girl from Brazil
you know
it just you know things happen
she's good though
well as I've said I kind of feel like
it's a lot better nowadays I mean yeah
you probably still get stared at and
[ __ ] like that but
I kind of feel like in the 1930s if you
weren't in a sideshow like people would
come and gawk at you and everything but
I kind of feel like if you just walk
down the street trying to be regular
person like I don't think anyone would
really let you right back then
you know and I'm not saying everybody
was like that because obviously
um you know something like people like
schlitzy and stuff like that I mean they
had people but usually the um the
sideshows and stuff were kind of their
own Community you know and they were a
lot more accepting and they were just
kind of like you know we have to take
care of all these people they all like
took care of each other which was good
because I don't think like The Wider
society would have I mean clearly
because this movie came out and
everybody was just like horribly
offended it was like a little scene you
know yeah and the thing about it too is
that
it's interesting I feel like most of the
um most of the performers that were in
this movie they seem to be cool with it
like I said they were all on the side
show or anything like that but a couple
of them later on did say that they
didn't really like that the way the
movie come out that they thought it was
a little bit exploitative which like I
said that's fine I mean obviously
everybody's gonna have different uh
feelings about it I think in particular
the woman that was in it that was like
the bearded lady
like she was in it but I think she
didn't really like how the movie turned
out later like she thought it was a
little bit offensive but by the
standards of the 1930s I feel like it's
not
I mean I you know I I don't know if I
really have any right to say but I
didn't find it all that offensive you
know what I mean I actually found it
really actually pretty sympathetic it
surprised me like how sympathetic it was
when I first saw it like for the 1930s
particularly because
usually
as I mentioned like prior to that if you
know people with deformities or you know
birth defects or things like that like
or people that were funny looking were
or different in some way were usually
portrayed as bad or portrayed as
villains so I kind of feel like this was
kind of a big step forward it's just
amazing that it took
30 years really until the 1960s for
people to like realize that that's what
the message of the film was people
didn't get it they really didn't they
didn't want to get it yeah I think they
didn't want to get it you know what I
mean
yeah mango said I think the thing that
shocked people deep down was that it uh
portrayed able-bodied people in a bad
light I think that's exactly what it was
and I don't know if you would have asked
people at the time like why are you so
offended I don't know if they would have
said that or if they would have known
how to like articulate it but yeah I
think they didn't like that normally
because you have to think too this is
1920s 1930s it was like you know these
starlets and everything being all
beautiful and glamorous and the fact
that the most beautiful glamorous woman
in the movie was a monster and she's a
[ __ ] she was a terrible horrible person
and I don't think people really liked
that well what it is is these people are
they're seeing images of people that are
you know uh supposed to uh discuss them
they're going well they're going like oh
my God that's terrible but then
that then what that turns out they're
the good guys and you shouldn't be you
shouldn't be reacting that way to them
to them and now you feel bad that you
know yeah I think that's exactly what
happens around and it turns around and
says uh hey you're you're only normal
just by luck yeah you could have been
like the like like these people you know
you better you know treat people well
you know yeah you know they're just
people and they didn't want to hear that
and I I was watching something earlier
too that said that made the point that
it's like well you know um if you live
until old age I mean eventually
everyone's gonna become disabled so you
better like be [ __ ] nice to because
you know you're not gonna live forever
either you're gonna start falling apart
and [ __ ] so yeah so like you said it's
just it kind of happens to everybody so
I think that's exactly what it was I
think people weren't prepared to deal
with their own prejudices prejudices
about people that looked like that like
I think you know when people went to see
the movie I think they were expecting
the freaks to be monstrous it's gonna be
the bad guys and that and if that had
been the case I think probably the movie
would have been successful yeah yeah but
because they were sympathetic and
because they were the heroes and they
got revenge on the beautiful people at
the end I think people were really
really offended I think I think the
freaks was referring to uh uh Cleopatra
and uh
well because you know what's interesting
I say who the freaks are right all right
and I think it was them
yeah well and the interesting thing too
I think the part with the Carnival
Barker at the beginning I think that was
added a little bit um later like after
they cut half an hour after out of the
movie like they were trying to pad it
out a little bit but it's interesting
that when they had that scene with the
Carnival Barker
like saying you know come in here and
look at this [ __ ] like or whatever and
then talking about
um talking about Freaks and everything
and then the very next scene I think is
Cleopatra on the trapeze yeah so it's
almost kind of like they cut right to
her like that's who we're really talking
about I think that's what it was I think
that's
um that's what that edit meant you know
what I mean yeah there's the free and
she was a murderous or an attempted
murderous and a [ __ ] yeah she sucked
she was awful yeah what a [ __ ] taunt
that woman was yeah I mean worse than
that like she tried poison that little
man yeah and the and the thing about the
thing about Hans was that he was so he's
not in love with her and [ __ ] yeah he
was he was It was kind of sad because he
was just so um enamored of her that I
mean everybody else knew they're like
look man like she's just laughing at you
behind your back and it's like they were
trying to tell him but he just would not
be swayed you don't understand yeah it's
like oh she's really not like that and
blah blah and everybody's like yeah she
totally is like that and she was like
she tried to poison him and everything
like at their [ __ ] wedding for crisis
Jesus Christ he's trying to steal his
fortune turns out he was an heir to a
fortune yeah yeah so you know I'd say
she got what was coming to her as far as
I'm concerned they turned to a duck lady
I was like good yeah super [ __ ] that's
what happens like I said she [ __ ]
around and found out it got started to a
duck I do I do wish they that they had
left in the Hercules castration though
because that would have been hilarious
and it's sad that they I mean if that if
that footage still existed I'm sure
somebody would have put it back in there
by now but I don't think it exists
anywhere unless somebody finds it
someplace but I don't think it's in
there because they cut it out before the
movie went to wide release see a lot of
that [ __ ] when it was shot on film that
degraded pretty quickly that too like
silver nitrate yeah so I kind of feel
like it's probably long gone and like I
said it wasn't even like oh like later
on it got cut it got cut before it even
got wide release it got cut after the um
you know the the test screenings so
nobody knows where that [ __ ] footage
ended up which is kind of a shame all
right so I guess we've been talking for
about an hour so we were gonna wrap this
up so tomorrow night is our main show so
hopefully you guys can drop by for that
we're going to be talking about the
Mormons yes I mean that which is a big
topic I kind of feel like maybe we
should concentrate on like the the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like the Mormon Wars and
okay yeah and maybe the white salamander
letters yeah yeah yeah we'll talk about
that we'll talk about and actually I
kind of want to watch
um because I think we watched murder
among the Mormons that was about that
forger bomber guy we might talk about
that a little bit um yeah and it's not
going to be anti-mormon per se there's a
lot of good well I caught it well I kind
of want to just get in because they did
have some weird [ __ ] happen in that
church and we talk about churches that
do weird [ __ ] yeah that's what I know
that's what I mean like I said I kind of
want to get a little bit like the
history and the beliefs and everything
but I mean honestly most people want to
like see the interesting [ __ ] which is
like murders and [ __ ] like that so we'll
do that and I think there's also because
that that uh one about the forger that's
on Netflix I think there's another
documentary on Netflix that's about
about a Mormon sect I think it's called
keep sweet
and I kind of want to watch that so I
might watch that like later tonight I
was reading a bunch of stuff like I was
trying to Cobble together like some
notes earlier today but I kind of want
to watch that and see if I want to
incorporate that as well
but yeah so uh yeah so thanks for
dropping by let's just talk about uh
freaks today it's actually on HBO max if
you would like to watch it it's a
classic and everyone should probably see
it
um so yeah we'll see you guys again
tomorrow night
bye